COLT MCANLIS: Good.
Test.
Can everybody hear me?
Can everyone see how bald I
am from where you're sitting?
Hands up if you can see
your reflection in my head.
So I have a really
tough job tonight.
My job is to try to keep
you entertained and awake
at this time of night, after
you've been fed and alcoholed.
So I'm going to try to
do that as best I can.
Let me introduce
myself really quickly.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm actually the team lead
for Chrome Developer Relations
Performance.
About a year ago, in
January, we actually
identified that the web
performance community was
good and doing
well, but we didn't
have someone focused on
bringing the message to people
constantly.
As talked about in the
previous talks tonight,
it's really easy to do dumb,
slow things on the web.
And one of the first things
we need to do with that
is fix it with education.
So we kind of defined
from the beginning
that after looking
at all the education
and looking at
everything out there,
there's really three
pillars of web performance.
Up until now, the web
as a whole has really
only focused on one of them.
All you've heard from
most performance experts
is, how fast does
your website load.
We've all seen the
studies that show
that one millisecond of time
actually related to $10 million
of lost revenue for
site X, Y, and Z.
And they only really
talk about network.
But in the modern age
of web applications,
we often tend to
neglect the other two
pillars of web performance,
rendering and compute.
A great part of the
forecast-- Forecastio?
Forecast-- I wanted to see.
He was listening.
That was good.
I wanted to test.
See, I've got to
keep you awake, too.
One of the great parts of
the forecast talk, I believe,
was when he really said,
we have to actually solve
this problem of
rendering because it
doesn't happen for free.
I think the existence of
the previous type of web,
where CSS animations
weren't something you even
had availability to, allowed
us to do really stupid things,
and the browser
kept us really fast.
But now, because we kind
of can tend our own yard,
we're running into
some problems there.
So when you think
about performance,
you should know that
network, render,
and compute-- you can have
problems in all three of these.
And much like Jake said
earlier, a huge problem
in one of these
portions can actually
cloud out issues that are
happening in the other two.
So as you're going through your
process of finding performance
issues in your website,
you need to make sure
that you're evaluating
all three of these
with the right tools
at the right time.
And what I'm going to do tonight
is I'm going to try to walk you
through some of the sites
that you've submitted--
ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-- and hopefully
bruise your ego a little bit.
No offense.
It's what we all have to do.
Quite frankly, I think one
of the big things we've
been trying to do with
the web performance
movement over the past year is
actually bruise a lot of egos,
in a way.
Because we're all programmers.
We're all smart.
We're too smart, quite frankly.
And we've got to be
taken down a peg.
Because we all know in
here-- everyone in here,
think about your coworkers.
And think about what
really motivates them.
99% of the time, if you
can bruise their ego
or challenge them or tell
them they're not good enough,
or the problem's
too hard, that's
what actually gets
them to move, right?
AUDIENCE: Or if
you pay them more.
COLT MCANLIS: OK, maybe, maybe.
If you've got Yankees
money, I guess so.
So this is the loop.
So this is what you
should all be thinking of.
Now I've got about 10 years
of game development background
under my belt.
I'm a C++ programmer at heart.
And I'm trying to apply a
lot of the lessons we're
using in game development
to web development.
Because in reality, we're both
dealing with real time media
interfaces.
So when you guys say, how
fast can something load off
an internet site, I'm
thinking, how fast
can that stuff be
streamed off a DVD.
It's the same problem we've
had, just 10 years later.
So when you're doing
your performance,
the main thing that you have to
do is follow these three steps.
The first thing is you
need to gather information.
You go open up Chrome DevTools.
You open up WebPagetest.org.
This gives you information about
what is going on in your page.
From that, you
actually need insight.
Because really,
what's a whole sheet
of floating point
numbers mean to you?
Nothing.
You need to know what those
floating point numbers mean.
And your tooling
system needs to be
able to infer what those
floating point numbers mean.
And then once you
have that insight,
you need to be able to
actually plan an action.
You have this data.
You have to then
go to your manager
and justify, please, let
me spend two weeks fixing
seven milliseconds of
load time from our website
because it matters.
And then you need to be able
to repeat this constantly,
constantly, constantly.
You need continuous
integration tools.
You need the ability to actually
track down who's check-in
broke the build.
Quick show of hands.
How many of you in
here actually have
some continuous
integration for performance
in your suite right now?
One, two, three, four, five.
Wait.
Were you just showing
me your Pepsi can?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
It's a cool can.
Bravo?
So maybe four, maybe five,
out of an entire room.
I've asked this question to
probably about 3,000 developers
this week while I've
been in New York
and meeting and giving talks,
and the total number of people
is close to about 15, with
the five in this room.
This shows there's a huge
problem in the web community
is that we're not actually
testing for performance
and giving it the gravitas that
we are our features and our CSS
and those pretty
little bubbly items
everywhere else on our pages.
And this is why we
actually moved forward
with trying to build a
better community about this.
So for you in the audience,
this is the only slide
I want you to take
away from today.
Burn this into your retina.
Tweet it.
Blog it.
Get a tattoo of it.
Get it tattooed, tweet me,
and I'll send you some swag.
Please don't get a tattoo.
Anything I say is
not representative
of any organization or
Google or the lawyers that
are affiliated with me.
All comments are my own.
Please do not get a tattoo.
First off, if you're
doing performance,
go to HTML5Rocks.com.
There's a landing page.
It's called Performance.
You click on the button.
I'm actually the guy
that maintains that page.
If you start there,
it's going to walk you
through the three pillars
of web performance.
You're going to be able
to go step by step on how
to find and address
the largest problems
on each one of
these three pillars.
Next is you need to
be following and using
the #perfmatters hashtag.
We actually started this
hashtag just earlier this year.
And we really wanted
to use #webperf.
We really did.
We wanted to use that hashtag.
It was out there.
But we didn't feel like
it bruised enough egos.
We wanted #perfmatters to
be this name, this brand,
this answer to a question.
And what we saw was that
very quickly, people
started posting links to
their friends' websites
and being like, yo, dude.
Why does it take 15 seconds to
load your site? #perfmatters.
Right?
We wanted it to be something
you could take to your manager
and say, hey, it
takes 15 seconds
for our site to load on mobile.
#perfmatters.
We want this to be a badge.
We are all egotistical
programmers.
Wear the badge.
Own the sticker.
Make it a part of your culture.
Make it a part of
your environment.
That's what we want.
We want attitude.
That's why you should
follow that hashtag.
Finally, check out the G+
Web Performance community,
if you're in Google+.
It's a cool place.
A lot of cool people
hang out there.
Some of them are bald.
Some of them post content.
I'm not saying who.
But you need to follow that
because really, if you combine
#perfmatters with the Google
Web Performance communities
and the articles coming
through HTML5 Rocks,
you're actually going to find
an overflow of information.
I bet most of you in
here haven't actually
dived into-- here,
we'll do this.
We'll do this.
Put your hand up if you've
read more than five articles
about performance.
OK.
Keep your hands up.
More than 10 articles.
OK.
Let's ramp this exponentially.
20.
28.
Ah.
Let's go 40 articles
on performance.
OK.
For those of you who
have had your hands up,
of those 40 articles,
how many of those
things did you implement?
Maybe 5, 6, 20?
No fair if you actually
did a talk earlier tonight.
I'm not taking your input.
So the point that we're
getting at, though,
is that for those of you
who haven't been reading
a lot of this content,
this is actually
going to be an overflow
of information.
Hopefully, you can find
it, you can guide it,
you can move through it.
What's the next one?
Yeah.
So what I'm going to do now
is with the rest of the time--
Pete, how much time do we have?
40, 60?
As much as I want.
Keep talking until
people fall asleep.
Good.
I can do that.
So what we're going to do
is I'm actually only going
to load these
websites on mobile.
Quite frankly, I ran
through these earlier today.
And most of your sites actually
fell over dead on mobile.
There were some interesting
use cases on desktop,
but quite frankly,
desktop's dead.
If you're not making your
site mobile and friendly
and fast there, you're
doing it wrong, period.
Period, period, period.
Mobile is all that matters
right now-- #perfmatters.
You can tweet that.
I'll give you a second.
No, go ahead.
It's OK.
#perfmatters, [INAUDIBLE], OK.
So we're going to take a look at
a couple of these really quick.
And I'm going to try to organize
these in terms of discussion
and pointing out
a couple things.
So if we don't get to
all of them, I apologize.
Please feel free to email
me later and curse at me.
Or do it on social media.
That's always fun too.
So what I've got here
is a little setup,
and you can actually
see my little phone,
so I can click on some stuff.
And what I'm using over here is
the Chrome Developer Tools ADB
extension.
So this is a fantastic
little-- who's using this?
Anyone using this?
No?
No fair if you're
hosting the event, dude.
You guys are cheating.
So this is a fantastic
Chrome extension.
You go to the Chrome Web Store.
You can actually download
and install this extension.
Basically, what it
allows you to do
is interface with the
Android Developer Tools
very easily and quickly.
So I can actually click on this
and go View inspection targets,
and you'll actually see that it
loads and shows me this Galaxy
Nexus phone that's actually
plugged in right here.
And I can actually
click-- well, I'll
close this so you can actually
see what this looks like.
I can click the Inspect button.
And what this Inspect
button shows is
it actually shows me what's
on my phone right now.
So this is one of the
sites, and I'll get to it
a little bit deeper
here in a minute.
But this is actually
what's on the phone.
You can see it's moving, it's
scrolling, it's doing stuff.
We go over here, and you can
actually see the network.
So if I hit Reload on my
phone-- and you can actually
see the network
request coming through.
This is not a desktop site.
This is actually a mobile site.
This is really good because I'm
actually testing on the device
that my users are using.
Wow, great comment--
#perfmatters.
One of you will
tweet it tonight.
It will happen.
I'll keep drilling it into you.
But the cool thing
is, you can actually
see what's going on here.
And notice, for this
particular website,
that it's actually
not done loading yet.
You can still see the bar
moving on the side over there.
And the funny thing is, if
you load this site in desktop,
you don't see that same problem.
So obviously, there's
an issue on the mobile
that is not showing
up on the desktop.
Again, we need to make sure that
we're testing things properly.
But the cool thing
is, we can actually
see all of the same events, use
the DevTools in the same way,
minus everything crashing
because of memory issues, which
might happen tonight.
I apologize for the live feed.
But we can actually go through
here and just record memory
and see what's
going on in memory.
And so let me show
you over here.
I can go through and actually
scroll and go back and actually
see how memory is adjusting
based on this stuff.
So if you haven't adopted
this Chrome ADB extension
into your tooling
and your testing,
you need to definitely do this.
Definitely get
this in your stuff
because no other tool allows
you this sort of integration.
And Chrome DevTools are
already top of the line.
This should be part of it.
So anyhow, enough
of me babbling.
So let's start with one
of the first sites here.
Come on, clicky clicky.
Now there's a native app
for you, slow when loading.
Right, Forecastio?
Aw, I'll get it right.
Sorry.
So we're going to try this
first one here, allout.org.
This was submitted.
Someone in the room
submitted this.
I don't know who it is.
Doesn't matter.
But we're going to take
a look at your site,
and hopefully, we're
going to make you upset.
So this is loading.
I'm going to show you what
the page looks like first.
So first off, we all
just watched it load.
This is on a 4G connection.
I'm not on the local Wi-Fi.
We can see that this actually
is not a mobile site.
I mean, I shouldn't
have to scroll.
Oh, I can zoom.
Yay.
But most of the site
is actually eclipsed.
We've got some sort of
spinner here at the top,
but it's a marquee movement.
We've got some other items
down here on the bottom.
Some stuff's going on.
So let's take a
look at what that
looks like in Chrome DevTools.
So I can go here, click Inspect.
Again, native
applications, they're slow.
So let's go to the Network tab.
And I want to take a look
at how this thing loads.
So I'm going to
hit Reload again,
and we're going to watch
all the assets come through.
And notice here,
on the bottom here,
you can see six
requests, 12 requests.
I'll keep scrolling
down to the bottom
so you can kind of see that.
Seven seconds worth of load time
before it's actually loaded.
So this down here on
the bottom tells us
that it took about six seconds
before content complete was
actually kind of issued, before
the page load event occurred,
and 7.9 seconds total.
8K actually came-- oh,
no, we're still not done.
9K came through, pardon me.
And so 34 requests.
We can actually see the
health of this object
and the health of this site.
Now 34 requests, that's
actually nothing.
9K, that's a drop in the bucket.
The Robitussin-laced
grandmother picture from earlier
could easily load
9K very quickly.
What's important here, though,
and I want to show you this,
is when we go up here and
actually sort by size,
we actually get a
different sort of sense
of the content that's
being sent around.
So we can see--
let me not do that.
There we go.
So we can actually
see the images loaded.
We can actually see that most
of the large assets here, 6.4K,
512 bytes.
We can see that the
large images here-- this
is actually interesting to me.
So this is a 1,024 by 576.
It's 213K.
Quick round of applause.
Who thinks that's too
large for a mobile site?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
OK, here's another one.
Here's 109K, a
little bit better.
Same resolution, though.
Anyone notice that?
Same resolution, half the size.
Now if anyone in here-- a
quick other round of applause.
Who's written a JPEG compressor?
One guy, two guys, three guys.
All right.
We'll get some beers
later, and we'll
talk about DCT coefficients.
I've had this really cool
idea that you can actually--
you know what, never mind.
So notice, though, that
this image actually
has a lot more data to it.
There's a lot more edges.
There's a lot more
noise to the image.
Yet it's smaller
than this one here.
This is actually mostly pink.
There's no reason that
the image with more detail
should be less size than the
one with less detail in it.
What this tells me-- I know
nothing about these developers.
I know nothing about the site.
But this tells me that
they're not actually
exporting this particular image
with the right compression
settings.
So another-- I like doing
these polls because it's late,
and I need you all entertained.
So how many of you
actually just export
your images at some
constant format.
Like when you do an export from
a JPEG, it's like on 12 or 80,
depending on what you're doing.
So no-- everyone else
hand-optimizes exactly
your exact, perfect PSNR
relationship for your JPEG.
Yes?
Is that what I'm hearing?
Because I saw like three hands.
So either you're all
lying to each other,
or you have no idea the way
that your images are compressed.
OK, round of applause for no
idea the compression quality.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: OK, fantastic.
So seeing this site
actually tells us
that this is a systemic problem.
And again, the 3,000
developers I've
talked to over the past
week all see this problem.
In a couple of
the other websites
I'm going to load
tonight, you're
going to see this show up very
prevalently that in general, we
as a web community do a
horrible, horrible job
of optimizing images for
quality against size.
Now in reality,
this isn't something
that's that difficult.
Most of us consider
a single way pipe.
We have artists or designers
that are working in a vacuum.
They're trying to optimize
for the visual quality
of the image.
Meanwhile, there's
bald engineers
in a corner somewhere
going, why is my site slow?
And there's this constant back
and forth between these two
camps about size of
images versus quality
of images and load times
and all this stuff.
Let me give you a
little word of advice.
If any of you are able to
implement something like this,
it's very simple to spin
up an Amazon EC2 instance
or even do this at
your desk and actually
run a compressor, a
command line compressor,
like libjpeg or
jpeg-turbo-- by the way,
jpeg-turbo is the actual
codec that we use inside
of Chrome for JPEGs--
and actually compress it
at various quality settings and
test the PSNR of the images.
PSNR, for those of
you who don't know,
is Peak Signal-to-Noise Ratio.
This is actually a
measurement of the amount
of noise and error
that's introduced
to an image, the
blockiness that actually
comes from the
compression format.
We actually have a
standardization process.
We call it PSNR, and that's how
we compare image compressors
to each other.
So you could actually take your
image, compress it at level 90,
see what the PSNR is, compress
it at 80, see what the PSNR is.
70, 60, 50, 40, 30.
If you get below 30,
you've gone too far.
Just stop at 30.
But the cool thing about
this is that you can actually
run 10,000, 20,000, 30,000
images through this process,
and for each one find the
exact right compression
value to give you a
PSNR of around 38 to 45.
So you're not actually
just exporting
to a single compression
number, a slider
that your artists have
no idea what it does.
You can actually
programmatically
find this value by implementing
a simple iterative process
against the command
line compressor.
That's kind of cool.
Round of applause for cool.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: I saw
some of you begrudgingly
go, that's not cool.
Let's save the
questions for the end,
if that's OK, because otherwise
I'm going to stare at Putin,
and he kind of scares me.
So let's take a look at
some other things here.
So I want to go over timelines.
So that was load time.
Everyone knows
the network stuff.
If you're not using
WebPagetest.org or ModPagespeed
or PageSpeed Insights
and all that stuff,
you need to be using all that.
So let's just take a
look at what this site's
doing while I'm doing nothing.
So now I haven't
touched this site.
To be clear, my
phone almost actually
went locked because
I haven't touched it.
I'm still not touching
it, but I want
you to notice what the
memory is doing on the top.
Now I'm a C++ game developer.
To me, the only thing that
matters for performance
is follow the memory.
I actually give a
talk at Velocity
yesterday where I, in
a very heretic fashion,
suggested that web developers
were really bad developers
because we're not
controlling our memory.
We're actually letting
JavaScript do it for us.
And because of this,
we have no idea
what's going on under the hood.
How many of you know
what your heap size is?
How many of you care?
That's another question.
I like that.
I like your outfit.
Is that like a
cummer-- What is that?
Is that like a real [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah, I like that.
That's cool.
I might have to get me one
of those. #perfmatters, I
got to get me one of those.
So again, I've touched nothing.
But notice this here on the top.
I don't know if you
guys can see it.
It's allocating between
7.5 megs and 9 megs.
I'm touching nothing.
Nothing's occurring
on the screen.
Yet two megabytes of data are
being allocated and cleared
in this environment.
Now I can actually
figure out what's
going on with this--
if I stop my recording,
too much information.
Let me just do a quick
record real quick
so I can clear all that.
So we can see something
on the timeline here.
So it looks like,
first off, they've
got two different timers firing.
So we've got widgets.js
and Chartbeat.
Chartbeat, I'm guessing,
is like an analytics thing.
I see this on a bunch of
sites you guys gave me.
And then widgets seems
like their thing.
So I'm guessing this is that
marquee scroll at the top.
They've got some
timer that's actually
moving those images around.
What I don't like-- pardon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: For widgets.js?
Oh, cool.
Oh, nice.
Widgets.js, Twitter.
Oh, cool.
So Twitter is actually
screwing this page up.
Go Twitter.
Is anyone here from Twitter?
Boo, Twitter.
So what we see
down here, though,
is we see recalculate
and paint and what not.
For our memory, this
view doesn't actually
tell us what's being allocated.
We can see where the events
are occurring and whatnot.
I can actually mouse over the
GCs when they actually happen.
More importantly,
though, I can actually
go over here to
the Profiles page.
Because I don't like
seeing that kind of memory.
And I can actually do a
record of heap applications.
So I can just hit start
and let this thing run.
And basically, what you're
seeing here is on this top,
you're kind of seeing timeline
view plus memory profiling
at the same time.
In the top, any of
these blue lines
is when memory
allocations occur.
Now when you see a grey line,
what the grey line means is
that memory has been freed by
a garbage collection process
somewhere.
So you can actually see a
new set that just happened,
and some of the
grey lines happened.
But these blues tend
to kind of pop up
in a very regular fashion.
Now in this, I can
actually go through here
and change the size of
my window and actually
see exactly what was allocated.
So in this single event,
at about eight seconds
in in my capture, about 3K
worth of data was allocated.
And we can see a similar
pattern over here.
I can highlight this
window, and we see another,
about almost 3K.
And over here, a similar window.
There's about 3K, plus
a lot of extra change
there that hasn't
been freed up yet.
But let me focus on
this guy really quick.
So here I can actually see that
3K came from compiled code.
So somewhere in this system,
deoptimization code came from.
Now for those of you
who are not versed
in fast path and
slow path JavaScript,
effectively what this
little block of data
you're seeing here-- see
that optimization data?
The way that V8 and most
modern JavaScript VMs work
is they will actually
try to optimize
your code on your behalf
because, I mean, come on.
You're a stupid programmer.
You don't know
how to write code.
Obviously, the VM
knows better than you
because it's a machine, and
it's fast, and it's smart.
So what it'll actually
do is take a code path
that you've written, and
it'll actually optimize it.
It'll manage the memory.
It'll make some fast
path optimizations,
and it'll put it out there
and start running it.
Well, the problem
is that it does this
with some assumptions about
the state of the environment
that it's in.
And it'll do this, and
oftentime, it'll break.
And it'll go, whoa, we
actually cause an exception
somewhere in the stack
due to our optimization,
because we're just
a stupid robot,
and we actually don't know
what we're doing either.
When this happens,
basically Chrome
has to create this new block
of code that's parallel
to the block of code you had,
delete your block of code,
put your new block of code in
the stack, and have it execute.
When that deoptimization
occurs, because the optimization
failed, it has to take
your old block of code,
put it back in, and
delete the block of code
that it just created.
So there are specific
code paths that
generally cause this to happen.
Closures are one of them.
How many of you are using
closures in your timers?
Don't applaud.
I don't want you
to applaud that.
Closures are one
of these things.
If you actually have
a closure running--
so it's very common
for people to do
set interval closure
comma 1,000, right?
That closure in
that set interval
is actually causing these
sorts of memory leaks to occur.
It's a deoptimization path
that V8 can't optimize around.
And so basically, every
single time you're doing this,
you're running into
this situation.
So let's look at something
else really quick.
So I want to go over
here and show you
what I'm seeing on the screen.
Now I've turned on a couple
modes on the developer tools.
So first off, you'll see
this beautiful little--
you can't see it too well.
I wonder if I can tilt my
phone just a little bit.
You can see up at the
top that I actually
have a little graph
showing me frame rate
as well as how much GPU
memory is being used.
So that's actually--
quick show of hands,
who understands how a
web page is painted?
It's like the same guys
that wrote JPEG compilers.
OK.
So for everyone else, let
me do this really quick.
How your page is rasterized
is a delicate ballet.
Really, it's more like boxing.
It's basically two people
smashing each other's faces
in for about six
milliseconds a frame.
Effectively, what happens is
Chrome will take your web page,
and it will dice it up.
It'll create square regions
of 256 by 256 tiles.
For each one of these tiles,
it'll actually spin up a thread
and actually rasterize all
of the pixels in that tile,
all of the WebKit--
well, Blink now.
Sorry, I've got to get
my terminology right--
all of the page elements,
and actually composite that
to a CPU chunk of memory,
32 bits per pixel,
256 by 256 tile.
And it'll rasterize
all that data in there.
Once that data is
rasterized, it'll
then upload it to the GPU.
When you scroll a page,
the GPU is actually
the thing that's
moving your page.
Now for those of you--
some of you in here
are young, much younger than me.
You may not know this, but
back before "Quake III"
was hardware accelerated,
we had something
called software rasterization.
Yeah?
Software rasterization?
"Heretic," "Doom,"
"Quake," anybody?
Any other professional
gamers in the house?
Yeah.
So back then, we used a term
called software rasterization.
This was generally OK,
but once we invented GPUs,
GPUs are basically
hardware rasterization.
They're built to take pixels
and put them on the screen.
They're dedicated
silicon for this.
But Chrome is actually still
using software rasterization
to paint the pixels
on the screen.
This means that
this is a slow path.
This also means that
every one of you,
right now, should be
really, really scared,
because how many of you have
actually tested whether or not
those rounded corners and drop
shadows affect your render
time?
They do, actually,
quite frankly.
If you go to "HTML5 Rocks," I
actually did a study on this.
Ha ha.
I'm sorry, that was
a leading question.
That was mean.
I knew that you didn't
know that answer.
But basically what happens
is your CSS effects actually
cause-- it has to be
software rasterized, which
means we have to actually go
and draw rounded rectangles
and then actually add a drop
shadow to the side of it.
And this actually
takes more time.
In fact, if you have
those two combinations
of things together,
it actually takes 4x
as long as each one
of them individually.
Which means that there's
combinations of CSS properties
that hurt your rendering
performance more than others.
Hopefully all of you
are going, dear god,
I have to test this right now.
And how you can test this, as
you can actually see up here
in this GPU, this
frame rate meter,
is that as you're
scrolling, you can actually
see the milliseconds taken to
render that part of your page.
Now what you're
also seeing here is
notice this big red box
that keeps popping up?
This is actually a mode
in Chrome DevTools.
Let me show you this.
And I know I'm spending
more time on this site.
As we go to the
other sites, you'll
actually see this
stuff play out.
But I need to kind of
test the groundwork here.
Is that in or left?
AUDIENCE: Left.
COLT MCANLIS: Left.
Oh, wow, OK.
I'll keep working.
So anyhow, I have show
paint rectangles on.
Basically, what this does
is when I turn this on,
it's going to show
a red rectangle
for every part of the page
that actually gets repainted.
So this actually tells
me what part of the page
is being rerasterized.
Which is really cool
to know because I'm
pretty sure all of you
will look at your site
and find that you've got some
little square icon like this,
but for some reason, it's
rasterizing like a 6x size
window of that, that all has
to be processed on the CPU.
This slows down your page.
It creates jank.
I hate that word.
Hitching, by the way,
hitching is the right term.
Every other medium,
video games, AV, movies,
it's called hitching.
Just, can we all
agree to use hitching?
No?
I'll get hitchfree.org later.
Anyhow, let me move
on to the next site
because I want to make sure that
we talk about some more stuff.
But basically, you can
see that on this site,
there there's a couple things.
First off, they're
sending two large images
to a mobile device.
They don't have a mobile view.
They don't have a
mindset of a viewport
for these mobile environments.
Plus it seems like their
marquee is actually
rendering and updating
different parts of the page
at different frequencies.
They're allocating about
a meg of memory per minute
or so when no one's
touching anything.
So if this is your
site, fix those things
because you need to.
And also, your load time
is pretty harsh, too.
So let's do this next one.
So this next one
should be pretty quick.
I just want to highlight
something really,
really poignant here.
So I'm going to close this.
Which view are you on?
OK.
So let's show you.
So this is DoSomething.org,
a cool little website.
It kind of just
encourages everyone
to do something interesting in
small, little-- small butterfly
wings change the course of tides
in Africa and all that stuff.
But we see it's a pretty
simple website, just kind
of a little strata of
images and whatnot.
When we go over here
to Chrome DevTools,
let's inspect this
information here.
And I'm going to put this
back on the Network tab,
and we're going to go
ahead and reload this.
So we can actually see that
the page loaded pretty quickly.
We got a lot of
information really quick.
About 2.9 seconds, so
this is a lot better
than the previous website.
We're right around that
three second load time.
And again, this is on my 4G.
I'm not on the wireless.
So that's pretty good.
10K transferred,
that's all right.
21 requests, not
that bad at all.
So let's again sort by size.
Let's see if anything's
coming up here.
I got a couple not founds.
That's not necessarily
a good idea.
A couple images here.
So this is interesting.
Again, another 106K image
that's being delivered
to a mobile screen that
obviously does not need 106K.
That one's a little bit better.
Well, not better.
I mean, that's a very
depressing image.
I didn't mean that
that was-- again,
my opinions are my
own and not that
of any organization
or secret service
that I'm influenced with.
So we can actually see
some of these images
may be a little bit
larger than others.
But for the most part,
this is actually nice.
Where did-- what happened here?
Did I-- this technology,
isn't it great?
So we can actually see, though,
that this page is actually
a pretty good example of
what to do on a website.
If you load this on the desktop,
what you'll actually see
is that there's larger
versions of these images.
They're tiled differently
with a different layout.
There's a different scheme.
But in the mobile
version, they really only
have one or two images
that are probably
too large for the mobile device.
But in the most
part, this actually
scrolls pretty quickly.
I know you can't see
it up in the top, here
but this is actually about
three milliseconds to five
milliseconds to actually
draw the part of the page.
And you can actually see
that as I'm scrolling,
notice that there's
no red tiles.
You don't see those
big red flashes.
What that means is that this
entire page has actually
been rasterized on the CPU
and uploaded to the GPU,
and it's been cached in the GPU.
And so as you're
scrolling up and down,
the CPU doesn't
have to do any work.
So this is what you want.
You want no red blocks
going on in your page.
All right.
So let's do another
site here really quick.
Because now I'm freaking out
that I only got 30 minutes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
Oh, we're going all night.
Let's just open
up every website.
OK, so this is the one we
saw a little bit earlier.
Sorry, I don't know if my
antics distracted you all.
Let's reload this again.
Let's see how the load time is.
So notice on the top here
that it's about halfway.
So this page hasn't
unloaded yet.
Let's just be clear about
what we're looking at.
This is an instant load.
Now we've actually gotten
to the loading part.
If this is your
website, I'm sorry.
Hopefully, you understand
there's work that needs to do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: It might be.
Let's find out.
So again, over here,
let's go to Inspect.
I wonder if I can just
catch this midstream,
if it'll just tell me
what that image is,
or if I have to hit reload.
It's still loading.
OK, here, I'll hit Reload,
see what goes on here.
Ooh.
Oh, web fonts.
OK, we'll take a look
at that in a second.
OK, so I hit Reload.
This is waiting to reload.
So obviously, there's already
some problems with this site.
Hopefully, someone in
here is going like,
uh, please stop
clicking buttons.
Please take my website off
of your screen, you angry,
bald man.
OK.
Let's let see how
this is going here.
So you can't see the screen.
It's still loading.
The font's just now appeared.
Let's take a look at
what's going on here
and see whether or not we can
discuss some of these items.
So let's sort by size here.
This is something I want
to let everybody know.
This is the first thing I want
to point out on this site.
This is a WOFF file.
It's a web font.
Round of applause if you're
using web fonts in your site.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Good.
Please stop.
Please, please stop.
This is a-- I don't
know if you saw this.
Yeah, web fonts look great.
They're awesome.
This is 38K for that web font.
And unfortunately, some
of these have been cached,
so you can't actually see the
true size of a lot of these.
But there's actually like five
or six web fonts on this page.
So you guys are kind
of getting a bum deal.
You're not seeing
how horrible this is.
But basically,
here's what happens
is when you've got
five web fonts,
each one can be somewhere
between the range of 40K
and like 90K for a font.
That font is required
before text can actually
be drawn to your screen.
So pop quiz.
What happens if you're
ready to draw text,
and your CSS is down, and
your JavaScript is down,
and your images are down,
but your WOFF isn't down yet?
Good answer.
I don't know.
No one said anything.
Good answer, nothing.
Nothing happens.
Chrome will do nothing.
Chrome will block.
Chrome will wait.
Chrome will wait for every
single one of your WOFFs
to come down before a
single character of text
is drawn on your screen.
AUDIENCE: Uh, it will
point at one WOFF.
It will render all the
text that uses that WOFF.
COLT MCANLIS: Jake
Archibald says I'm dumb.
If that single WOFF is
visible, it'll render that one.
Now Firefox will do it a
little bit differently.
Basically, what
it'll do is it'll
wait three seconds, right, Jake?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
It'll wait three seconds.
Maybe you should continue.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: I'm having
an awkward mic moment.
Basically, what'll
happen with Firefox
is it'll start the
request for the WOFF.
If it hasn't been
downloaded in three seconds,
it'll actually keep
allowing that to download,
but it'll actually display
the font with a default.
Like it'll just see Arial.
So if you're actually
seeing this on Firefox,
you'll see like three
seconds of nothing,
and then you'll see Arial, and
then when the font comes in,
you'll see it pop to whatever
the font's supposed to be.
And so you see this flicker.
I see it.
You see it a lot on mobile,
because these mobile devices
are actually 6x slower
in hardware, just
across the board-- probably
for at least another two years,
depending on which hardware
manufacturer you're trending--
than what you're
seeing on desktops.
Not only is it slower to
download these things,
but these WOFFs are actually
very complex spline paths
that have to be interpreted by
these underpowered ARM chips
as well.
Anyone in here written
a software rasterizer?
Cool.
Spline paths are slow.
Anyhow, WOFFs are bad,
and you should feel bad
if you're using them in
your websites right now.
Now, things are happening that
are trying to optimize this.
I know that there's
people talking
about different ways to compress
WOFFs and different ways
to use these type of
fonts in different ways.
But please note that you have
them as part of your site,
you should feel bad.
Now let me see if I can--
can I Shift-Reload this?
I don't know.
I can't get the data from cache.
But we also see in here
a couple of these things,
and I can't show you this.
But these images are
actually a little bit larger
than they should be as well.
These are OK.
Was that Willie Nelson?
I don't know.
Again, there's another WOFF.
This PNG, where was
its header on that?
This one's a WebP.
Ooh, fantastic.
So this guy's
actually using a WebP.
Interesting.
I don't know what that's doing.
AUDIENCE: That was
the accept header.
COLT MCANLIS: That was
the accept header, yeah.
So at least a WebP
did come down.
However, we see that-- let's
go down here-- again, 124K.
So again, you guys are
getting the bad rap
because I'm not doing a
cached fresh reload on this.
But basically, this
site is using--
it's actually passing full
megabyte, two megabyte images
down.
It's got the WOFFs in the
direct path to rendering,
and so that's going
to take a long time
before text will show up.
In fact, the image will try
to progressively load in
before all the text does.
And this will annoy
your users a lot more.
So let's try to avoid that.
All right.
Let's try another website
here really quick.
Let me go over to this.
Is anyone sad yet about
the state of things?
Is anyone going
like, wow, I wonder
how my site does under
this type of scrutiny?
If so, then yay,
I'm doing my job.
I can get paid this week.
Cool.
That was actually pretty quick.
That actually wasn't that bad.
Let me do that again.
Yeah, that actually
wasn't that bad.
Here, let me see if I can
hard-- load, load, load.
Good.
Cool, OK.
So this might be a good site.
Let's take a look at this one.
So we'll hit Inspect again.
We'll load it up.
Let's see here.
Scrolling actually seems
pretty smooth on this site.
Doesn't seem that bad.
We can move stuff
around pretty easily.
Let's take a look
at the Network tab.
Let's hit Reload again.
Again, unfortunately,
all of this stuff
is coming from the cache now.
I should've used
my other tablet.
Dot com, CSS, not that bad.
22K CSS, 27K CSS, 200K.
I don't like this 192K JPEG
that's only 920 by 300.
Notice this.
So this is 192K
for an image that
is a quarter of
the size of Putin.
Show of hands, who
knows what that means?
Yeah, not optimizing your JPEGs.
I think there's actually
some other bad examples here.
Here's another one, 240K.
Oh, oh, 240K, 920 by 300.
Does anyone off the
back of your hand
know what this is if it
were a raw image size?
So it's 920 times 300
times 24 bits per pixel?
Get back to me.
Jake'll give you some swag.
Oh, there's a Facebook icon.
Only 9K, yay.
Well, OK.
100 by 100 is 9K.
That seems a little
bit excessive, right?
That seems like there's actually
some bloat going on there.
I wonder if there's like
a negative JPEG encoder.
Make it larger.
By the way, if any of you are
going to be in San Francisco
next week or have a chance
or have the internet,
I think, definitely tune into my
talk I'm giving on compression
on the web.
And hopefully, if you've
seen my talk yesterday
about being scared of closures,
if you see my talk next week
on compression on the
web, hopefully compression
will scare you after
that, and you'll
trudge toward that
monster with a wary eye.
But anyhow, 100K, 100K
pixels, 3.9K in size.
So that actually seems a
little bit excessive there too.
Here's, again-- those
are the same images.
Here's another one.
These are really large.
180K being sent to
my mobile device.
Now the reason this
loaded-- again,
this loaded a little fast.
This is a bias because I've been
testing these things all day,
and this is coming from cache.
So you're not really feeling
as much pain as you should be.
AUDIENCE: If you go to the
bottom of the [INAUDIBLE],
you should be able
to disable the cache.
COLT MCANLIS: Beautiful.
All right, Jake
Archibald for the win.
Here, let's hit Reload now.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Oh, feel it.
Feel it!
So awkward right now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] JPEGs.
COLT MCANLIS: They kind
of should be, yeah.
Oh, so-- no one's hiding
their face right now,
so maybe the guy who put
this site in isn't here,
or you've got a
great poker face.
I will not bet
money against you.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Oh, then they shrink.
COLT MCANLIS: And then
they shrink, right?
So that's actually
a great point.
I'll bring this up
really quick, too.
How many of you have
responsive websites?
OK, you're doing it wrong.
Let me ask that in a better way.
How many of your
responsive websites
will actually resize the
image that you've been given?
Jake.
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by resizing it?
COLT MCANLIS: You
got a CSS resize.
Are you changing the
properties of it?
If it comes down as 1024
by pixels by 1024 pixels,
and you display it as
900 pixels by 900 pixels,
or something like
that, anybody resizing?
You're telling me
every single one of you
gives exactly the right pixel
ratio for every single device
that loads your website.
Is that what I'm hearing?
All right, that guy's
hiding his face,
so I know he's doing it wrong.
You know what?
At least you're honest, brother.
I got some swag
for you after this.
So here's something a
lot of you don't know.
Decoding a JPEG or a PNG
or a WebP file actually
takes time from your CPU.
And in fact, you know
how I was talking
about those tiles
getting rasterized?
What happens is before a
tile can be rasterized,
Chrome actually has
to go decompress
all the images that
are in that tile.
Now when that tile is
evicted from the cache,
we're going to have to repaint
it again sometime later.
Well, lo and behold,
there's actually
a texture decompression
cache as well.
So there's a chance, a very
high, high, high chance
on mobile devices, that we'll
actually decompress a JPEG file
and then have to resize the
uncompressed version of it.
So you're actually getting full
32-bit pixels actually being
resized from 1024 to 512.
And then the next time you
have to render that image,
you have to decompress
it and resize it again.
So if an image is split
between two tiles,
you can run into a
very awkward situation
where you have to decode and
resize that image for each tile
that it's split in.
So if you're resizing your
images dynamically right now,
this could be a
problem for your site.
Hopefully, some of you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], should
we not do dynamic websites?
COLT MCANLIS: Save the
questions for the end.
AUDIENCE: OK, sorry.
COLT MCANLIS: I
said it to that guy.
I gotta say it to you, too.
Was that because I
called you Forecastio?
OK.
That's all right.
Much love.
Anyhow, so I think
we kind of see
that this website
has some issues.
And most of it is
on the Network tab.
Let me go ahead and turn
on continuous show paint
rectangles as well, because
I want to show this off too.
So see that red rectangle?
So you can kind of
see this little one.
Let me show it on
the screen here.
You can see this will pop it up.
But watch this red rectangle
happen full screen.
Did you
See that?
See that again?
Poom, poom, poomp.
Poom, poom, poom.
I see this almost on every
single site on this list.
Basically, they've
got a marquee on top.
And that marquee,
for some reason,
is actually invalidating the
entire page below it as well.
So the actual div that's
expanding this thing that's
getting repainted is touching
every single pixel on the page.
Which means that even sitting
here doing nothing, actually
the CPUs just sitting
here spinning and spinning
and spinning and spinning
and working and working.
And that's actually going to
make scrolling not as smooth
as possible.
And you can't see it.
I can feel it a little bit here.
This is actually a
pretty janky website.
Up at the top, it says that our
average frame rate right now
is about 18 frames a
second, 17 frames a second.
I can actually really
feel this on mobile.
Now I have 30 minutes.
Yes.
15 minutes of filler.
So obviously, this is a problem.
And because when I see
something dynamic like this,
I generally think that memory
is going wonky as well.
So let's go ahead and do a
timeline and hit Record again.
Let's see what's going on.
We've seen this before, right?
Same pattern we saw
with the other site.
We see just kind of memory, just
being allocated and allocated
and allocated and allocated.
Let's hit Stop and see if
we can drill in and see
what the culprit is.
Again, I know nothing
of these websites.
I'm just a primitive
C++ developer.
Your web development
scares and confuses me.
So let's go to Profile,
and let's do a record heap
allocation.
So we can see that
memory's a problem.
Now let's dig in a
little bit deeper.
Let's record a heap allocation.
OK.
Again, I'm not touching
anything on the website,
and memory, 10K, 5K, 10K, 5K.
Let's hit Stop.
Let's try to drill in
here on one of these guys.
Let's just look at this one.
Compiled code.
Looks familiar again.
Oh, wow.
It's almost like we've seen
this exact three lines of code
before.
So again, I know
nothing of this website.
I haven't even looked
at the source code yet.
But something in here is
already passing a closure
to a set timeout-- or
a set interval, sorry.
Set timeout is a different
operating system.
But there's some other
stuff going on in here, too.
It looks like some other
relocation info is going on.
I don't see any
injections, which is good.
So no one's calling eval,
because otherwise we'd probably
see this 6K worth of
information-- someone laughed.
That's probably good.
Eval is bad, and
you should feel bad.
So if you're using closures
and eval, just get out.
Just get out, dude.
I'm going to see a tweet.
Colt says, use set interval with
closure and eval #permatters.
Yeah, with a WOFF,
inside of a WOFF.
By the way, I saw
someone the other day
that actually had a WOFF
embedded inside of a CSS.
And I was like, OK.
That's just a bad idea
from all principles.
So the CSS gets bloated, and
then the WOFF has to be--
Anyhow, we see that this
other part is an array.
Now this is interesting.
So when you see
this array object,
this means this is an
actual JavaScript array that
is allocated
somewhere on the page.
And you can see
some of it is coming
from internal with V8,
the code deopt data.
But otherwise, the relocation
info, here's like a null.
A null array is just being
created for no reason,
and no items are
being added to it.
We can go down here
to string, and we
can see a GM string has
been created somewhere.
Let's scroll this up.
Do we have any information?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Yeah, that's what's
going on right here.
So there's regex
occurring somewhere.
A GM is being created.
And then there's some
system level stuff.
This is mostly
dragons and krakens
and other things going
on under the hood.
If we expand this
a little bit, we
can actually slide over and
see, again, compiled code.
There's another relocation info.
Let's see if there's
a deopt this time.
No?
That makes sense because
the spike's not as high.
See around this guy.
Compiled code, relocation.
Yep, spike's not as high again.
So again, deopt
is actually what's
causing the memory spike here.
And then of course, that's
causing inflation in our heap.
So we can actually see
there's a couple problems.
Obviously, they're sending
too much data down the pipe.
This page is loading slowly.
The person should feel bad.
They've also got some
timers and some closures
and some memory leak
issues that are causing
some friction with their users.
Let's load another site.
Here we go.
Try this one.
Chrome always, thank you.
All right, So
let's see this one.
Who thinks this is
going to be a fast site?
Show of hands.
No hands.
Good job.
You win.
I like the spinner.
We're trying to load.
We're letting you know that
we don't know how to do this.
Oh, sorry.
That was below the belt.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: I'm sorry.
I thought it was a good idea.
We see it in Gmail.
I don't know.
It's kind of like,
hey, we're not
ready to figure out how
to stream content yet.
We saw load.
That was good.
So let's do this again.
Or actually, let
me show-- scrolling
doesn't seem that bad.
Let's click on something.
That was actually pretty fast.
That was actually
a little too fast.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
Let me go back.
OK, I'm back [INAUDIBLE].
Let me click on something else.
Like, trust no one.
I don't trust anybody.
Wow, that actually loaded a
lot faster on the main site.
Let's drill in here.
Hold on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: No, no.
Dude, you're messing it up.
Jake, who's got the microphone?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
COLT MCANLIS: I didn't
interrupt your talk.
So let's take a
look at this here.
So I'm going to
go to Network tab,
and I'm going to hit
Reload again here.
Boom.
We're going to take
a look at this.
Let's see what's going on.
So it was really weird.
The main page loaded slow.
That was awkward.
But then all subsequent
clicks loaded actually really,
really, really
fast, which tells us
if you can't get
the main page right,
why are you getting
the sub clicks right?
That's kind of awkward.
So we're still loading.
We're still loading.
Again, I always
sort by size, right?
Because I'm a big dude
who says that memory
is where the performance
problems are.
We can actually see
that they're loading--
and I'll kind of give
away the punch line here.
But these images were on the
sub pages, not the main page.
But they're being
loaded on the main page.
Anyone figure it out yet?
Basically, what they're
doing is they're
loading all of the images
for all of the articles
that you would click to before
the main page is loaded.
So they're basically
trading off.
They're saying, your
initial load time
is going to be really
crummy, but every click
after that's going to be golden.
So they're kind of giving up
that initial three second load
time to get one second
load times later.
I don't know how that--
maybe that's a discussion.
Again, here's a WOFF.
Anyone like WOFFs now?
Answer should be no.
But yeah, this is
really interesting
that we're seeing
some of these images.
Let me see if I
can sort this again
and see if we can't get
better-- here's another PNG.
Again, this is not
on the main page.
So let me hit Back here.
And let me, again, let's
show you the main page here.
Even clicking Back
takes some time.
No?
Backie?
No, I guess not.
AUDIENCE: You can't go there.
COLT MCANLIS: We're stuck now.
There we go.
So yeah, notice this right here.
So this was one of the
last things I clicked on,
and they have a
little drop down.
So basically each one of
these items, the images
and the extra content is
loaded in the main page, not
the subsequent page.
We're kind of seeing that break
down in a lot of these charts
here.
So they have a couple lower
res versions here, too.
So remember when that 100 pixel
by 100 pixel Facebook icon
was 9K?
Here's a 320 by 180 that's 10K.
So again, don't trust
your Facebook icons.
I would like to say,
don't trust Facebook,
but I'm not allowed
to say that on camera.
Shit.
Sorry.
Again, perfect.
Here's a 320 by 180
that's exactly 9.1K.
So again, I think all of
you should be questioning
how big your images
are, but I think
this Quartz site is actually
kind of an interesting case
study because they've
definitely traded off
one type of load time for
another type of load time.
And I'm not really
sure why or where
the justifications of that are.
But I think we
can definitely all
agree that the 20 years
that we've had on the web
have all kind of accumulated
that the initial load time is
pretty much the most
important thing because that's
the first thing your user feels.
None of you have seen this
site except for the one guy who
submitted it, and all of you
felt the pain of this site
loading for me hitting a button.
And it doesn't matter how much
the clicks after that are.
Most of us would have left the
site before we got to that.
Let me go over here, too.
I want to show this.
So notice this--
oh, I moved now.
But this YouTube image here.
So if I click this
button, you'll
see the red boxes again
kind of show up here.
So we can actually see that the
video-- that part of the page
is being re-rendered.
So you can see again that
it's showing that the--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
COLT MCANLIS: Nope.
Don't care.
Nope, done.
Stop.
Let me click.
Done.
What I'd really
like to show here,
and this isn't really showing
up on the main screen,
and I'm sorry.
But can anyone see
this orange line
right here, this orange line?
So one of the other
interesting things,
there's a talk that I gave at
Google I/O this year on this.
It's called "Web Page Design
with the GPU in Mind."
So what happens is
certain elements on a page
are kind of-- imagine
your page is a plane,
and all of your images
and all of your text
exist on this plane.
Some of those
things are actually
propagated to its own plane so
that the web page can actually
scroll in the background,
and this other plane
can actually scroll
relative to it.
So this is relative
scrolling concept.
Let me actually show you
this on a big screen here.
Let me load up HTML5 Rocks.
And let's-- nope, I
typed in the wrong thing.
Because I can type.
Who's on my internet?
Watch my Wi-Fi go down now.
We'll try that.
There we go.
So I'm going to pick this,
just a random article
with some random guy on it.
Some random, good-looking guy.
I think he's pretty
good-looking.
Bald is beautiful, I hear.
So let's go ahead
and turn on-- this
is Chrome DevTools
on a desktop site.
I know I wasn't going
to talk about this,
but let's do force accelerated
and show composite layer
borders.
So turning on layer
borders here shows us
what we're seeing normally.
The first thing you see is
that the blue lines here
actually represent the
tiling of the page.
And this orange line
actually represents
something that's been
promoted to its own layer.
So how many of you
are using translateZ?
TranslateZ, translate3d,
this is the hardware
accelerated fast path,
the silver bullet that
makes your web fast
because you're suddenly
using the GPU on the web.
It's so amazing.
Actually, that's
not how it works.
What happens is when you use
translateZ or translate3d,
you're actually promoting
these pieces of content
to its own plane.
And this is actually a
separate set of tiles.
So remember how I said
the GPU will actually
scroll your tiles on the screen?
When you actually
use translateZ,
you get another layer that
the GPU also controls.
Now I'm going to see if I can
do this because for some reason,
we get paused in the
debug-- too much clicking.
So as I scroll here, notice
how these objects on the side--
watch this.
The table of contents
has not orange, right?
And so once it gets
to a certain part,
it actually gets promoted
to its own layer.
The orange border represents
different layers in GPU memory.
And then as I scroll
down the page,
they actually stay static.
Any time you have relative
scrolling content on your page,
you're actually going
to want to promote it
with this translateZ
or translate3d.
Now beware that this actually
puts a lot of pressure
on your GPU.
So for all of you
who are just going
to start putting translateZ
on every part of your pagee--
we saw this happen
a lot because it
was supposed to be
a silver bullet--
every one of these tiles,
every one of these layers,
is actually contending for
residency inside of your GPU
cache.
Which means the more of
these separate layers
that you've actually promoted,
the slower your website
is going to be.
So you get an inverse
effect with it.
Because basically, your
GPU is getting overtaxed.
More tiles are being
evicted from your cache,
because more things are
fighting for residency.
It's actually going
to slow down your site
because your CPU is
spinning up more.
Anyhow, enough with
the desktop stuff.
Desktop's dead.
No one wants desktop.
OK, let's go back over
here to this thing
because the mobile web is sexy.
What was I showing off?
Yeah.
So Quartz, this QZ site,
this is actually a little bit
interesting because we see
mostly that as we're scrolling,
notice the big red spots
that keep popping up.
Let me see if I can get
it to do that again.
Yep, see it?
So something's going on.
It turns out-- I'll spare
you the punchline here.
What's actually occurring
is that these guys
are doing something with
a scroll handler in here
where they're actually trying
to catch what I'm doing.
They're trying to
catch my little scroll.
reposition things.
And as soon as
they touch the DOM,
the whole DOM has
to be recalculated.
As soon as the whole DOM
has to be recalculated,
all of the tiles
have to be redrawn.
So as soon as they try to
catch what I'm scrolling
and reposition things
manually, they're actually
invalidating the
hardware compositing
and the GPU scrolling that we're
trying to do on their behalf
and actually messing up
their entire frame rate.
How many of your mobile sites
are catching a user input
like this?
Yeah.
I saw that.
At least you're honest with it.
Forecast.io, they know
what's going, guys.
I got it right.
He didn't-- no,
he still hates me.
That's OK.
All right.
Let's do some other websites.
Pete, how are we doing on time?
15 minutes?
I can load all the
websites in 15 minutes.
So let's look at a
couple other ones here.
Let's see.
Let's take a look
at something good so
that everyone walks
away from here
with feelings of
happy bunny times.
Sorry, I just called somebody.
So this is Meetup.com.
OK.
So we didn't see
a loading spinner.
That was kind of nice.
But it did take a
little bit long to load.
In general, though,
let's see how it scrolls.
That's actually pretty fast.
Notice-- let me turn
the show-- let's
open the DevTools again and
see what kind of red things
are occurring and what
kind of load times
we're experiencing here.
So turn on DevTools.
Let's hit Reload and see
how the network performs.
Not that bad, not that bad.
On the device, I'm
actually seeing
things starting
to pop up already.
I notice no WOFFs in the code.
That's really good.
Oh, there is one.
Son of a bitch.
Where did that come from?
Oh, bogus.
Well, maybe they're not using
that on something critical.
Let's sort by content here.
This is really cool to see.
We've actually got-- a
44K JavaScript is actually
the biggest part of the page.
I'm surprised that's
not jQuery at 191K.
How many of you are using j--
you know what, never mind.
Just never mind.
OK, actually, this image
is popping up to the top.
60K JPEG, 320 by 226.
That's maybe a little large.
Another 60K JPEG,
another 50K JPEG.
This is really interesting, too,
because we just saw 340 by 226s
on the previous site that
were about 10K, right?
So again, someone's not
optimizing JPEGs the right way.
In fact, there's
actually, on the article
that I put on HTML5 Rocks
about image compression--
let me see if I can tab
over there really quick.
So this article that
I did was actually
"Image Compression
for Web Developers."
The entire point of this article
was to talk to all of you
in a very frank way
and kind of discuss
the back story of where
image compression works.
Plus I'm a really
big fan of parrots.
They're kind of cool, especially
the digitally pixelated ones.
Anyhow, there's some
great content down here
about JPEG information.
And it actually shows that--
here it is, right here.
Let me see if I
can zoom this in.
No, too far.
OK, so this is actually-- I feel
it's important to kind of break
away from our regularly
scheduled bashing
of these websites--
because that's
getting a little
depressing, right?
Everyone's getting depressed?
So this is actually a test
that an external person
did on the compression
quality of the images that
are being served by the
top websites in the world.
And what you're actually
seeing here is most of them
actually just use
a standard value.
So all Window Live background
images are exactly 82.
Regardless of what the
PSNR is, they choose 82.
It's hard coded.
So they might be able,
on some of the images,
to use a level 64 and
actually reduce the size more
because they use 82.
Wikipedia are all 80 for
every one of their images,
regardless of the
content quality on it.
YouTube is about 70 to 82.
That's kind of good.
It shows that they're actually
doing some dynamic scaling,
although it's unclear whether
or not it's actually manually
scaled, where they have an
artist actually changing them,
or they have some sort
of dynamic solution,
like I was saying.
Yahoo, 69 to 91.
Again, they may have some more
responsive version of that.
Facebook's are at 85.
And Google image
thumbnails are about 74.
Here's the really
interesting-- Twitter user
JPEGs are anywhere
between 30 and 100,
which means that
for some images,
they're actually doing nothing.
And some images, they're
doing everything.
This actually tells me-- I
don't know if anyone-- no one's
in here from Twitter, right?
This actually tells me that
they may have something dynamic
actually testing the noise
ratio of the compression
there and actually serving
you the most optimized JPEG
at the best image
quality possible.
So that's really cool.
That's really cool
to see that someone's
doing that out on the web.
OK, back to doom and gloom.
OK, we were over here.
So yeah, so these
images probably
are a little too
large in megabytes.
They're probably
not optimizing it.
Chances are-- nope,
that's not an image--
chances are they're just
using a standard one.
So let's hit Timeline.
Let's just hit Record.
Let's see what's
going on with memory.
I'm not touching anything.
Memory's increasing.
Not too much, 5.5, 5.6.
Again, we've got these
timers getting fired.
Fine.js, I don't even
know what this is.
Meetup script mobile find.
OK, so apparently it's trying
to meet me and find me.
That's kind of creepy.
Mobile base.
So that's weird.
So they've got two
separate timers
coming from their own website,
doing two different things.
And again, not
touching anything.
Nothing's happening, nothing's
moving, but we're at 5.6 megs.
So this is like a slow leak.
It looks like there's a slow
closure or something being
tossed to this.
So let's take a look at this,
see if we can't drill in.
Maybe we get some insights.
Oh, yay.
It is a jQuery library.
Can we summon the
power of pretty print?
Aha.
That didn't help.
I'll try that again.
There we go.
Oh, mustache.
Interesting.
Who uses mustache?
Can anyone explain this
line of code to me?
AUDIENCE: It's a JavaScript
[INAUDIBLE] derived from it.
COLT MCANLIS: So this is
causing a memory leak.
Can anyone fix this?
Not now?
OK, that's cool.
Take your time.
That's all right.
We'll get back to it.
But basically,
we're seeing again,
this kind of looks like
an anonymous function
calling some factory
objects, testing some object
definitions.
This in and of itself
doesn't look bad,
although it is calling another
anonymous function down here.
Sometimes the
pretty print spacing
doesn't get it all right.
This might actually be sort
of a closure in a closure.
It looks like we've got one
close there, one open here.
Something's going on.
Any of you who are using
third party libraries,
it's actually really easy
to fall in these traps
where they're allocating
memory and doing stuff
on your behalf that may
be negatively impacting
your performance.
And we sometimes
ignore these faults
and don't track
these faults down
because the fact we get like
event propagation or something
else.
Like, oh, I get a callback
when something occurs.
That code you can actually
write in about 100 lines
of your own making and actually
keep it memory performant.
But instead, we pull in
these large libraries.
So it's important that
you know these trade-offs
when something like
this is occurring.
Let's do another website.
Pete, we got what,
10 minutes left?
Yeah, about 10 minutes?
Let's see.
What haven't we done here?
So I have to load this because
I really don't get this website.
And I really want to talk
about the website more
than the performance
characteristics.
So this is called
Game of Phones.
Is this your site?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: OK, cool.
I really don't get this website.
But it's here.
So we can take a look at it
from a performance perspective.
Basically, what
happens is someone
will record-- from
what I can tell,
they're like very politically
charged, angry arguments.
And you sign up,
and someone will
call you and play this
recorded message that's
like, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Rally.
Fight the power.
And then you have to call
someone else on the list
and try to regurgitate
what you heard.
And so it's kind of like
the game of telephone
that you play as
kids, and you're
trying to get all
the way through.
I have no idea why people
are even doing this.
Like, I hate getting calls
from my wife, much less
random strangers
on the internet.
I'm on the internet because
I don't want you to call me.
Send me a text or something.
Anyhow, personal thing.
I'm sure it works
for you, brother.
I don't get the internet.
I'm too old.
That's my problem.
AUDIENCE: I've had people tell
me it's the only phone calls
that they will answer.
They will answer
phone calls from this
and from their mother.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, dude.
Game of Phones, awesome.
You know what you need to do?
You actually need to get the
voices from "Game of Thrones"
to actually do the
call, and then it
would just go through
the roof, dude.
HBO might sue me now.
Sorry about that.
Anyhow, let's look at this
from a performance perspective.
There's really
nothing on this page.
I mean, it's kind of text.
But we're going to
run through it anyway,
just so you guys can kind
of see the differences
in these things.
So am I here?
OK.
By the way, did you see
actually what showed up?
Was this on the screen?
Sorry.
So this is Game of Phones.
Again, it's just text,
people calling each other.
But this is it.
12 requests.
The interesting thing here
is 107K, that's a little odd.
Like we're seeing some other
pages come in below that.
Mainly this is coming
from a concatent.
So Bootstrap is being included.
I'm not really sure why
this needs Bootstrap.
I guess the cool
kids are doing it.
And here's the funny thing.
We got bootstrap.min and then
CSS that replaces Bootstrap.
So that's a thing.
And then jQuery.
And here's another Bootstrap
again, and then telephone-gram
and then another jQuery.
Are you using two jQueries?
AUDIENCE: I should
mention that I've never
made a web page before.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
You're using two jQueries.
Do you know you're
using two jQueries?
AUDIENCE: Now I do.
COLT MCANLIS: Now you do.
OK.
And then I like the GIF, right?
It's sprite sheeted, I guess.
Here's the cool thing.
So a 300 by 120 animated
GIF is only 4.4K,
yet we were seeing like full
JPEGs that were like 9K that
were static, right?
So I'm not really sure
what else do with this.
Let me hit Timeline and see
what this is doing here.
This is kind of
a little awkward.
So your jQueries
are using memory.
So this is kind of telltale.
Do you have a timer?
It looks like you
have a timer on your--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], maybe
the audio player is using it.
COLT MCANLIS: Maybe
the audio player.
Yeah, it looks
like yeah, it does.
So it looks like
there's a timer here.
I don't know if you
guys can see this.
It looks like
there's a timer here.
And you can see this red square
up here, just the Play button.
Just like that Play
button has a timer that
needs jQuery and Boostrap--
two jQueries and Bootstrap--
and is allocating like a meg of
memory over like seven seconds.
So that's a thing.
Lots of rasterizes
occurring in here.
Lots of recalculates.
So not only is it
repainting, it's
actually like updating
the DOM to repaint.
Let's look at this again.
That's updating the DOM.
Don't know why.
Maybe there's a cool
jitter effect there.
You know what?
Maybe I got this wrong.
Maybe I'm actually
looking at the Matrix.
Am I looking at the Matrix?
That would be kind of cool.
I'm like-- sorry.
I'm having fun.
It's late, and I have
to keep you all awake
for like another five minutes.
So anyhow, I don't
like this trend.
You're actually allocating
more memory faster
than the other websites
we looked at it.
It's probably because
you have two jQueries,
but anyhow, let's dig in.
So let's go to profiles.
Again, follow the memory,
find the performance problems.
So we follow the asset
memory to figure out
where load problems are.
We follow dynamic
memory to figure out
where compute problems
and render problems are.
Can I click this button, please?
Clicky.
You've allocated too much
memory for your site,
and I can't click.
Oh, there we go.
OK.
So let's do record heap
allocations, hit Start.
So that's kind of interesting.
You guys see this pattern?
So this is actually really very,
very regular allocations that
are occurring, two
different sets of it,
but they're almost
deleted immediately,
except for the
stuff that happened
at the beginning of the trace.
So we're seeing the grey lines.
So the grey lines mean that what
was allocated has actually been
freed now.
This is kind of odd.
I kind of want to see
where this is coming from.
I like to dig in and
figure out why I'm so bald.
So we have the whole
thing, yada, yada, yada.
Let's actually just
highlight this guy here.
So array, what's--
transition array.
So something's going
on inside of V8.
All these are being deleted.
Compiled code.
Is this a deopt?
No, relocation info.
So it looks like there's
just some sort of cases
where jQuery is executing--
and again, I see this a lot
with closures.
Closures, for some reason,
tend to bring up this pattern.
jQuery's kicking
off a closure that's
causing a reflow of your entire
page for like a five pixel
by five pixel icon.
So you still loaded faster
than the other sites.
Bravo.
Round of applause for that.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Real web
pages don't need images.
COLT MCANLIS: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Real web
pages don't need images.
COLT MCANLIS: There you go.
You know, I'm a fan
of the text web.
That requires drinking to get
more information out of that.
Anyhow, let's load
up another one.
Pete, how are we doing on time?
AUDIENCE: You've
got five minutes.
COLT MCANLIS: Five more minutes.
OK.
Let's clear up quickly,
because I'm actually
really interested to try this
Robitussin and whiskey thing.
I think we may have
something on there.
AUDIENCE: I highly recommend it.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Let's try-- here we go.
Let's try this CBN Week.
And we're done.
I think at this time,
I don't actually
need to tell you guys
what I'm about to do.
This is-- no, I don't
want to translate.
I used to be able
to speak Chinese.
It was a beautiful language.
So you kind of know
what I'm about to do.
I'm going to load up networking.
I'm going to see what images
are too large, what JavaScript
is too large, what you're using
that you shouldn't be using.
We're going to
try to cull assets
and get rid of
extra network loads.
I thought the points
about sprite sheets
was perfect earlier.
By the way, they shouldn't
be called sprite sheets.
They should be called atlases.
You should actually see my
Udacity course rant on this.
Everywhere else in the
world, in video games,
in film and everything,
we call them atlases.
You know what?
Never mind.
Anyhow, let's see
some scrolling.
Not that bad.
Let's head over to DevTools.
Let's take a look at this
under the microscope, right?
Let's go back to network.
My computer said, I'm done.
All right.
This wil be the last
site, and then we'll
actually get to
all the questions.
And I think we're going
to do a group question.
Right?
Fantastic.
So that's interesting.
So there's already 89
requests, 92 requests, 93, 95.
1.5 megs transferred so far.
1.9-- 2 megs.
2.195.
Let's see if we
can go [INAUDIBLE].
So here's something
interesting up here.
So notice this grey
bar right here.
So in Chrome DevTools, when
you look at this Network tab,
basically, you see two values.
You see sort of this
semi-transparent
and then this opaque
portion of these items.
That semi-transparent
value is actually
how long the browser spent
waiting to receive the asset.
This is one of the reasons
that sprite sheets are actually
so important for you, because
each browser has a set
number of limits
of open connections
that it will allow
to a single server.
For Chrome, I believe
it's around six.
Which means if you have
six requests in flight,
it'll block the rest of the
requests until a slot opens up.
Think of it like a
caching FIFO or whatnot.
And so Chrome actually shows
you this here on the timeline.
You can see some of
these actually waited
a very, very long time.
In this case, it
was actually spent,
what is this, 471
milliseconds waiting.
It wanted to request
this asset, but it
couldn't because there were
other things in the pipe.
And you can kind of see that
this is a function of the fact
that there's about 100 requests
and 3.6 megs transferred.
For those of you who don't
know, the average website
size right now, according
to HTTP Archive,
is about 1.1 megs.
And that's for desktop.
They haven't really got into
a lot of the mobile testing
just yet.
But obviously, mobile
shouldn't be 1.1 meg, right?
So obviously, there's
too big a content here.
So let's see if there
is any big offenders.
Let's see if images
are a problem.
Who thinks images are a problem?
AUDIENCE: Show of hands.
COLT MCANLIS:
There's a 300K image.
200K, 197K, 161K.
152K.
What is in that image?
I think that's bigger than raw.
Yeah.
Yeah, obviously, these
images are too big.
They're not being optimized.
They should be fixed.
Let's take a look at timeline.
Let's see if anything is
going on with memory here.
Anything crazy?
Slow.
Again, timer.
We see this same pattern.
So we see almost
all of these pages
are falling into
the same pattern.
Also, almost all of these
pages, and some of them,
in rare cases, are all using
jQuery or jQuery twice.
Closures are being passed
off to timers for things
like ads or analytics
or marquees.
And this seems to
be a common pattern.
But this is obviously is
causing a lot of memory
and a lot of churn and some
other weird things going on.
I can look at the
frames times here.
And so let me actually do this.
I don't know if I showed
you guys this tool.
Nope, cancel.
So as I'm scrolling here--
it's not picking that up.
OK.
Never mind.
I won't show you that tool.
Anyhow, let's be done
with this for the evening
because I think Pete has
some other stuff he wants
to talk to you
guys about tonight.
So thank you for
your time tonight.
Perfmatters.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll let you start
the clap in a second.
So here's how you
get a hold of me.
If you guys, if anything today
was controversial or something
worth tweeting or
something you just
want to ask more questions
about, go ahead and find me.
Make sure you join the Google+
Web Performance community.
There's a lot of
great stuff there.
Please, for the love of
god, use #perfmatters.
Follow #perfmatters.
It's a brand.
You should wear this at work.
Everything you do, you should
be challenging your employees,
your managers, the
owners of your company,
#perfmatters,
#perfmatters, #perfmatters.
It's going to be the
thing that separates
the billion-dollar
companies from everybody
else on the mobile
web in the next year.
In fact, it already is.
It's already [INAUDIBLE].
Challenge everyone.
Hold them to the
standards of #perfmatters.
Now you can start the clap.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Thank
you for your time.